Crew member: Water!
Narrator: Look behind the
scenes of this massive tsunami
in 2012's "The Impossible."
You'll see that the filmmakers shot it
on a recreated set at one-third the scale.
A smaller set meant less water to control.
Even for shots that weren't
filmed with miniatures,
the challenge was controlling
the unpredictable elements of a storm
while making scenes look as
wild and random as possible.
These tricks in "The
Impossible" were replicated
and built upon 10 years later
by the same director and DP
to engineer the perfectly chaotic storm
in "The Rings of Power."
Older movies with limited equipment
had to avoid putting actors and crews
in real water environments.
Instead, films like "Ulysses"
and "Swiss Family Robinson"
shot ocean storms with model
ships in miniature tanks.
And when you're destroying
a miniature model
that took significant
time and labor to build,
you often only get one take.
Today, films like "The Impossible"
still use scaled-down models
to create ocean storms,
but they've found new creative ways
around those past hurdles.
To recreate this 2004 Indian Ocean tsunami
hitting this resort in Thailand,
"The Impossible" built a model of the site
at one-third the scale,
the smallest set that would
interact with the wave
in a convincing way.
Since they'd have to capture
the shot in one take,
the director of photography, Óscar Faura,
set up a 10-camera apparatus
to catch every angle.
And to make sure they
got the wide, ugly impact
that they wanted on the very first try,
the team ran extensive
wave-generating tests ...
Crew member: Agua!
Narrator: Ultimately achieving
the right level of messiness
by rushing 1,000 tons of
water over the model set
with the power of eight
F1 racing cars behind it.
But the key to getting convincing results
was combining miniatures
with other methods,
including the most popular
tool for filming ocean storms,
giant water tanks.
Naomi Watts and Tom Holland
filmed most of their scenes
at Spain's Ciudad de la Luz studios,
home to a nearly
400-foot-long seaside tank
capable of rolling out
hundreds of thousands
of gallons of water.
That kind of control over
water is why Hollywood
most often films its ocean
storms in tanks like this one
or Pinewood Studios' tank
in the Dominican Republic,
the site for aquatic scenes
in "The Lost City" and "Old."
The water tank will give you
all of the control that you need.
The waves will look the
same every single day.
The visibility will be
the same every single day.
Everything out in the ocean,
it's just a moving, floating set.
Everything in the water
tank can be serviced
from the parking lot and from the trucks.
Narrator: Even on a windless day,
the ocean never looks still.
So a tank needs waves and wind to break up
its mirrorlike surface, which
often means wave machines.
These machines plunge into
the water and just send swells
into our set, so it
doesn't look like a pool.
Narrator: For "The Impossible,"
the team modified the
design of the giant tank
so that it had 33 submergible pumps,
which would be hidden on camera
and help move over 35,000 gallons of water
through the tank each day.
All of these techniques came to the fore
when building the ultimate
storm for "The Rings of Power"
with a team of expert storm makers helmed
by the director-cinematographer
duo from "The Impossible."
We went back, and we tore
apart the sequences they shot.
We took the film, and we
went through it beat by beat.
But for the tsunami, the
water came up slowly.
It was more of a rise as a giant wave,
whereas we were in the midst of the sea,
in an overwhelming sea.
Narrator: So the team drew
on real-world references too.
Ron: We go to storm-chaser material
and look and see what
it actually looks like.
What does the waves look like at sea
in a giant kind of storm like this?
Narrator: After extensive
previsualization,
the team tested the
plausibility of the shoot
with a miniature water tank.
Then they shot the episode
in two real water tanks,
the underwater portion
in a smaller dive tank
and the rest in a
10-foot-deep outdoor tank
capable of holding 2 ½
million liters of water.
Over the tank, the team
installed a retractable roof,
which allowed more control
over the lighting conditions,
making it easier to extend
the set in postproduction.
But water doesn't just
absorb light; it reflects it.
So "Rings of Power" swapped out
the color of the backgrounds
depending on the time of
day they were depicting.
We had the ability to switch
it to black for night scenes,
to white for the fog scenes.
Narrator: And for day scenes,
they used a blue screen
that was slightly less blue,
a technique used on "The Impossible."
The VFX team could still
extract actors from it,
as with a normal blue or green screen.
But when it was reflected
in the water, it didn't look
like somebody was having
a digital blue party.
You know, it looked like kind of sky.
Narrator: For the actors inside the tank,
the team built a raft.
Ron: We went out into
the tank with the raft
and started figuring out, safety-wise,
how can we keep the raft
tethered to one spot
so it doesn't get pushed
around in the waves,
but yet still looks real?
Narrator: The solution
was a hydraulic base,
like what Dean used on 2018's "Adrift."
To show the yacht in that movie
going through a hurricane,
Dean's team mounted it on a gimbal
paired with a robotic 200-ton digger.
On "Rings of Power," the underwater gimbal
attached to the steel base of the raft.
Dean: It then gets soft,
either balsa or timber
that goes on top, which
has a soft covering,
so it's not going to
hurt the actors at all
when they're rolling and
flopping around on it
and getting washed on and off.
Narrator: Safety was paramount here
because of what the
actors had to stand up to.
Crew member: Three, two, one, go!
Narrator: Creating all those waves
required a two-pronged approach.
The team took cues from
earlier work in "Adrift,"
which involved two dump-tank
chutes mounted on trucks,
each holding 4,000 liters of water,
along with a big eight-cannon
air mortar for spray effects.
That was all way too big for
the scenario, for the raft,
'cause the raft was 2.4 meters,
and the boat that we
did was 17 meters long.
Narrator: So on "Rings of Power,"
the 4,000-liter dump tanks
became 750-liter ones,
and at the bottom of the chutes,
the team cut little fingers
in the kicker plates
to disperse the water,
which helped make the waves
manageable for the smaller raft
and helped to get the look they wanted.
Dean: So it really more
envelopes them in a spray
than one solid mass of water.
Narrator: The dump tanks provided
the specifically timed waves,
but for the continuous chop,
the team hauled in five
14-ton construction diggers
with big steel plates mounted on them,
manually operated from
different spots around the tank.
There's that much resistance
on the big steel plates
so that the waves that
they generate would come in
and they'd pick up and
put a big broken lip
on the top of them that
then catches the wind
and whisks across.
The waves end up coming
back and rebounding,
and so it makes it really
nicely messy and horrible
once the waves have reached
the optimum sort of size,
and then the dump tank comes in on top.
Narrator: The result was convincing,
at least in the close-up.
In a wide shot, we knew that
we were going to have to
extend and create CG water
and really make foreground waves
that made it even bigger and scarier.
Narrator: But water is famously difficult
to render realistically with
CGI, especially ocean water,
which is constantly transitioning
between different shapes.
So for "Rings of Power,"
the studio ILM created
a digital ocean machine that
programmed the look of CG water
given a range of variables.
So it was getting a system
together that would allow us
to say, you know, how
choppy should this ocean be?
How windy is it? What time of day is it?
Narrator: Artists could
even include little details
like digital streaks of froth,
which better ground the waves in reality.
It also helped that the
waves only became CG
around 6 feet outside the actors.
The water that actually is touching them,
splashing around the raft
itself, is mostly real.
Narrator: Practical flourishes
pulled the whole storm together.
Ron: Anything that touches the actor,
anything that makes hair
move or anything like that,
is always best done practically.
So all the rain and the wind
and everything that was
hitting them is practical,
and it needs to be.
Narrator: It also needed to
be powerful. For wind ...
Dean: We have V-8 car engines
mounted on purpose-built fans,
8- to 10-foot-wide blades
that push a large volume of wind on cue,
and there was three of those
being used at any one time.
Narrator: To make
torrential pours of rain,
the team could have
used massive sprinklers
or rain-bar structures
but instead opted for
a firefighting method,
pumping water through the arm of a crane
into spinning cellar nozzles.
This allowed for 360-degree coverage
and more variable movement.
Dean: It's pushed out
over the filming set,
usually a little bit towards the wind,
so that by the time it hits the actors
it's caught with the wind
and goes over the raft.
Narrator: All that rain was
clearly caught on camera
thanks to the controlled lighting
that backlit the water droplets
and also helped the flashes of lightning
translate powerfully on-screen.
Those were pyro effects
set off through a remote firing system,
which provided a second reason
for the retractable roof.
Ron: When you do lightning
strikes, they illuminate
so broadly that you want to make sure
the light's contained and
pushed down into the set.
This way, we got maximal
strength from our lightning.
Narrator: With so much done
practically on "Rings of Power,"
the VFX team could focus on the details,
like adding these sharp lightning bolts,
painting out cameras and equipment
reflected in the water's surface,
and then seamlessly weaving
together the real and CG water.
The fact that storms are chaotic by nature
goes a long way to tying
all the effects together,
from waves to wind to rain.
Ron: The great thing about a storm at sea
is the sea becomes very
choppy and the wind is blowing
and there's lots of stuff
going on in multi directions.
Made it a little bit easier.
Narrator: Of course, creating these storms
only looks like chaos.
So it's all a very
choreographed sort of thing
to bring together.
It's like a song.
You always have to hit the
same beats over and over.